but you do want the extra protection of
band-aid plastic strips
they take better care of little cuts and
scratches they stay put
yes even in hot soapy dishwater neat
fresh colored almost invisible
that was a band-aid brand adhesive
bandage commercial from the 1950s
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
the band-aid
one appealing feature has always been
the product's flesh tone
finish but whose flesh tone just this
year manufacturer johnson and johnson
decided
to expand the colors of the product
similar to the line they released
over a decade ago and then scrapped
it's just one example of a movement that
includes another maker of first aid
products
putting racial sensitivity first
toby meisenheimer a father of six is the
co-founder of true color bandages
it's just a small one right he's made a
medical grade brand to match an array of
skin tones
a need he discovered while tending to
his adopted son
our acrobatic three-year-old kai had
nicked his forehead came to me crying
and i went into the cabinet and grabbed
a band-aid and
put on his forehead and we sat on the
couch and cuddled and it was kind of
like
for the first time the scales fell from
my eyes 38 years of life and how have i
not noticed this before
in 2013 he searched for an alternative
and about a year later ran into
orthopedic hand surgeon dr
raymond warrapa he designed a better
functioning bandage for knuckles and
fingers
inspired by his own son christian it's
amazing to see where
we were and a team of fathers was made
along with two other members
true color bandages was born
we make bandages for all shades of skin
and that's the beauty of it i think is
uh
by combining our efforts we can you know
accomplish
more together and uh have an offering
that i think
uh sends the right message especially in
this in these times
so so what is your message to the
medical community when it when it comes
to inclusion
yes the bandage helps with healing
physically but there's also a emotional
psychological aspect to what it does
just seeing that
you're acknowledged for who you are and
their options out there
it took my breath away that message was
received over 2
thousand miles away by dominique oppelon
for the first time in my life i know
what it feels like to have a band-aid in
my
own skin tone you can barely even spot
it in the first image
for real i'm holding back tears he
tweeted that feeling
and hundreds of thousands of people
worldwide liked back
including star wars actor john boyega
and that started a conversation about
race
i didn't expect to have the reaction and
so it just shocked me it really
took my breath away and
you know i felt silly for having that
reaction uh
you're still having it i see it in your
eyes
yeah there's a part of me that still
does feel silly there are far more
important struggles like again police
brutality
like employment discrimination to me
this was just this was part of a broader
story of racial exclusion
and it was just a small symbol even
today
products advertised as nude are not nude
for everyone
from high heels to undergarments
athletic tape
to even crayons we start off life
with images in a coloring book you're
right
i remember as a little girl there was
never a color
that described that i could describe or
ascribe
as me same thing same exact thing
and so i felt when i saw the drawing a
portrait that it wasn't me
and i just didn't feel complete i didn't
feel included
and i just didn't feel like that was me
find your color mimi dixon manages brand
equality and activation for crayola
she launched colors of the world this
summer a crayon pack
dedicated to just about every skin tone
it was important for us to do it in the
right way
isn't it just varying the colors of the
nude spectrum
it is not we want true colors that
represent skin tones right so
we're crayola and we know color we don't
necessarily know skin tones as you can
see this is a little pinker
they brought in a makeup pro victor
cassal
the former chief chemist of mac
cosmetics who even co-founded his own
beauty line
this is going to change things people
will can identify with themselves
in a box of 24 crayons okay
so wait so how do i find my color okay
on the back there are panels
um that you can put up to your wrist
look at all of the colors
for everybody this is for everyone this
is everybody this is
everyone you put four colors in your
hand so now you just start
coloring you just make a little swatch
actually that is your color i am medium
golden people that is your color
that is your color crayola's expansion
of skin tone options began
in 1992 but this new pack is a first
because it's marketing them as a source
of inclusion
why did you choose to market the colors
of the world
separately not in the traditional 32
pack
or the 16 pack this is
you know skin tone crayons and so we
wanted to make sure that again that was
clear
so 20 years from now it might be
in the it could be a bigger fact right
most certainly
it's not just the crayon it is about
feeling included being seen
feeling valued how do you expect this to
impact your bottom line
it wasn't necessarily about the bottom
line but for any business
money does matter they're seeing that
african americans money is green
and there's a lot of it and the impact
of widening the spectrum of inclusive
product lines can be profitable
according to cheryl grace senior vice
president with nielsen holdings
which tracks african-american and
multicultural consumer trends
african-americans buying power right now
at 1.4 trillion dollars
is about the equivalent of the buying
power of
mexico or spain and the 1.8 trillion
dollars that we're projected to spend
in just three and a half years is larger
than
the uh today's spending power or gdp
of russia of canada and most of the
growth in the united states has actually
come from multicultural
consumers and the fact that ten percent
of of blacks and ten percent of
hispanics
and i think twenty percent of asian
americans
married outside of their race tells you
that that's only going to continue
and you can't afford to leave that much
money
laying on the table and as brands try to
connect with the current social climate
consumers will ultimately decide if the
company's
intentions must align with the products
they sell when we really want to achieve
change in the world it's often done at
an individual level it's done in the
context of a
of a relationship it's dr w and i
working on a project
together despite our differences despite
the fact our skin color doesn't match
but
it's the beauty of that diversity that
is diversity and healing
i love the story behind the product
their story
and i just have to point out we shot
this part of it
before comic 19. when you were close
together we were really close together
but you know this is about folks who
traditionally have felt
invisible and and now feel seen it seems
like the thing i want to say why did it
take so long
yeah it's like what that idea of until
you think of it until you see it till
you live it
you may not be there it never dawned on
me that a band-aid was supposed to match
my skin
your immediate your medium golden yeah
it was one of my friends
he said medium golden you're high yellow
i was like rusty o'kelly i love that you
took the makeup industry coming into it
to get those skin tones right